vous pouvez jouer le rapport de forces
de haine
vous ça fait plus d'un an que thomas
toutes les preuves et vous allez plonger
n'ai pas beaucoup changé parade passe en
temps de crise sur le seul le ventre
ouvert les tripes à l'air appel au
secours
fréquentait la même université j'avais
les convictions politiques puis m'a
séduite
il ya huit ans il disparaît pour vous
plaindre c'est fini on vous a déclaré
persona non grata sur son territoire
cet homme a été formé aux techniques de
combat dans des camps terroristes
annappes résistant il va poser des
bombes les femmes les enfants des
innocents bambins
balcons grâce à nous tous le monde te
respecte comme planter avec tout ça
qu'est ce que c'est bon
mauvaise idée
son tour le 11 septembre au cinéma